[Music]
can I help you yeah I was just looking
just let you caught me in a look you
look good but you look really great in
that ice cream store
I mean thought it'd look great now you
look like you lost pound or two I would
say since last I saw you maybe more in
the upper area I would say oh you only
like me because I had fake boobs in then
yeah the upper area you sound like
you're a little disappointed because I
lost weight
I want to spoil it for you but guys like
breasts okay I mean if this is type of
tension I'm gonna get I shouldn't even
get paid boobs at all weren't very hard
it's a joke it's just a joke sorry you
know what I've had enough of this um
I've worked very hard to where I'm at
I'm lost a lot of weight and I'm very
proud of what I've done I mean I want
you to get to know me from me not my
boobs look there's more to me than that
I'm sure there is you know but I really
like curvy women Wow could be but no I
don't want I don't say Haiti gonna be
when I get money boobs I'm gonna have to
be on the lookout for what this guy
arrogant [ __ ] like you make us women
who have stigmas in our head that y'all
men want us to look a certain way you're
one of those men and I'm sure there's be
a guy that would love all this curves
and sorry you wasn't able to even touch
it
[Music]
you